true passion is always silent
religion protects souls wounded by
circumstances
art as a nectar of soul gathered in
sufferings
a human can be great not only due to his
mind but also feelings
only powerful love can overcome those
tiny issues that arise during family
life
one might be a great person not only due
to his mind but feelings
love as a competition of tenderness and
care
art is a wonderful tool to correct the
imperfection
truthfulness is the basis of any dignity
the only evil is a word that weakens the
spirit
happiness should be the only aim in life
in the end the main thing in life is the
life itself
no human being can live in complete
inactivity
care is the spring that feeds the family
life
life teases humans there is always
something unattainable in life there is
always perpetual temptation and eternal
dissatisfaction
human being grows at the moments of the
highest tensions
art is a powerful means of correcting
human imperfection
life is learned from books and works of
art perhaps even to a greater extent
than from life itself
art is the stored honey of the human
soul
remember love is all a woman has to give
but it is the only thing which god
permits us to carry beyond the grave
what matter is if a man gaineth the
whole world and lowe's at his own soul
a thought will color a world for us
only in rare instances and with rare
individuals does there seem to be any
guiding light from within
let no one underestimate the need of
pity we live in a stony universe whose
hard brilliant forces raged fiercely
in order to have wisdom we must have
ignorance
nothing is proved all is permitted
she merely beamed a fatty beam she was
almost ponderous and pink with a
tendency to a double chin
i was a moral coward and he was not
losing his life and desires through fear
which the majority of us do
every person according to his light said
ames you must help the world express
itself use will make your powers endure
the strong man wants to be allowed to do
the little man wants to stop him
morality and ethics are nothing but
footballs where with people strong
people play to win points
how dismal is progress without publicity
if you have that unconquerable urge to
write nothing will stop you from writing
how true it is that words are but the
vague shadows of the volumes we mean
do not choose a woman as your wife whom
you would not have chosen as a friend if
she were a man
all forms of dogmatic religion should go
the world did without them in the past
and can do so again
love is the only thing you can really
give in all this world
when you give love you give everything
are but the vague shadows of the volumes
we mean a little audible links they are
chaining together great inaudible
feelings and purposes
you